Richard vous restez en plateau avec nous
on va écouter à présent ail modi vous
êtes donc venu pour témoigner du
quotidien de votre quotidien celui de
votre fils également 37 ans il souffre
d'une forme de sclérose en plaque
Catherine zulato l'a rencontré on
revient ensuite sur ce
plateau Christophe modui a 37 ans il
souffre d'une forme de sclérose en
plaque depuis l'âge de 17 ans si vous
habitez Manil et àot son visage ne vous
est pas inconnu tous les ans le jeune
homme participe au Téléton un mot guide
de sa vie
espoir de donner un peu les moyens à la
recherche de pousser un peu plus loin
les recherche et il faut savoir que ça
bientôt être le cas ils vont réussir à
trouver quelque
chose ça va être long mais ils vont
réussir à trouver Christophe reçoit une
perfusion une fois par mois ce qui lui
donne un réel tonus la patate comme il
dit sa maladie fulgurante au début est
aujourd'hui
stabilisée il semblerait d'après notre
médecin traitant que on approche
effectivement vers des traitements qui
seraient beaucoup plus efficaces et et
donc aujourd'hui on essaie de maintenir
le niveau de tonus et puis de de santé
de Christophe à peu près
à étal pour que on puisse attendre
effectivement donc ce ce nouveau
traitement un combat mené en emble la
famille Mau sera donc présente à
manilamo tout le weekend pour témoigner
et aider à la collecte de dons les
pouvoirs publque et enfin l'État n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens pour dévelop
enfin et même les laboratoires j'ai
l'impression que les laboratoires sont
sont pas forcément toujours très en
pointe dans certaines recherchesin donc
ça coûte très cher et donc c'est bien
évident que si si nous-même y
participons on peut espérer que d'autres
viendront aussi participer en tout cas à
magie pratiquement tous les ans on bat
des
records ODIL modui je voyaz regarder ce
reportage il a beaucoup d'énergie votre
fils ah oui tout à fait toujours ça oui
tout à fait très très battant depuis le
début he com comment vous vous vivez
justement cette maladie on vous a pas
entendu dans ce reportage on a entendu
votre épou on a entendu votre fils on le
vit ben c'est pas toujours facile hein
c'est pas toujours évident mais bon on a
l'habitude maintenant et puis on est
toujours avec lui donc il est toujours
comme il se bat lui donc il nous donne
de l'espoir à nous aussi donc nous aussi
on se bat avec lui en fait donc puis
comme il a toujours le moral donc on
peut pas faire autrement que il nous le
redonne même des fois quand nous on a un
petit coup de de mou donc c'est lui qui
qui nous remte le moral il est très très
battant comme vous dites hein le
diagnostic a été fait à 17 ans 17 ans
oui comment vous l'avez appris comment
vous l'avez ressenti comment ça s'est
passé B je l'ai appris d'une façon assez
bizarre parce que au début il titubait
donc je pensais qu'il avait un petit peu
fumé
éventuellement à 17 ans 7 ans on me
disait bon et puis finalement je me suis
rendu compte qu'il arrivait plus à
laisser ses chaussures qu'il avait un
œil qui qui changeait un petit peu de
place il avait du mal à à parler et je
l' emmené donc voir un spécialiste qui
m'a dit il faut faire des examens et
puis au bout de 3 semaines on m'a
annoncé qu'il avait en plaque et ça a
été assez fulgurantensuite l'évolution
ah oui terribleement il est tout de
suite monté en flèche il a été 2 ans
pratiquement 2 ans après il était en
futeil rouant et aujourd'hui les choses
se sont plutôt stabilisé elles sont
stabilisé parce qu'il a eu des
traitements qui on qui ont eu à la salle
pétrière donc il a eu de la
chimiothérapie pendant 2 ans et
maintenant il a de la cortisone tous les
mois et c'est stable pour l'instant en
espérant que ça dure comme ça la
recherche qui avance ça vous rassure
également c'est un moteur pour vous
engager parce que vous êtes présent tous
les ans he sur Oui Oui B on fait le
Téléton depuis moi je suis membre
fondateur d'OTM donc ça fait 7 ans déjà
déjà bien objectif Téléton man
l'associationis déjà avant avec la FNACA
donc moi je m'occupe du centre du centre
de restauration
et puis bon bah Christophe il se promène
dans le il connait un peu tout le monde
quoi il se promène là-dedans et puis ben
on espère tous les ans qu'il y aura un
petit peu l'avancée supplémentaire c'est
lui qui donne la motivation pour les
dons aussi lorsqu'il va à la rencontre
des gens et c'est votre témoignage qui
est important aussi pourou tout à fait
oui oui les gens de le voir comme ça ils
sont bien contents de le voir aussi
comme ça ils le connaissent depuis
longtemps maintenant puis de voir qu'il
a toujours comme il dit la patate c'est
quand même important à aucun moment vous
n'avez perdu espoir perd du courage en
tout cas oh bah il y a toujours des
moments de dé frement au début quand on
sait pas exactement où on va et puis
quand on voit que ça c'est fulgurant
comme ça on se dit ça va s'arrêter où
quoi c'est pas c'est pas évident hein
mais après bon ben on s'y fait hein je
vais vous dire on se fait à tout hein et
quand vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui pour les
dons il est peut-être un petit peu plus
difficile de de mobiliser même s'il y a
plus d'animation on en parlait tout à
l'heure sur ce plateau avec le le
responsable départemental mais il est un
petit peu plus difficile vous pensez
qu'il y a un peu moins de solidarité
aujourd'hui que le temps de crise temp
toujours autant de solidarité on l'a vu
l'année dernière malgré la crise on a
quand même bien travaillé et puis c'est
les gens sont très motivés finalement et
char des témoignages comme celui-ci vous
en entendez beaucoup dans le département
oui oui bien sûr et puis et puis partout
en France et puis c'est vrai que c'est
c'est extrêmement motivant de rencontrer
d'abord de rencontrer les malades mais
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure dans dans
la première partie du journal de
rencontrer les chercheurs aller au
généton c'est un truc qu'il faut faire
une fois dans sa vie même si on n'est
pas touché par une maladie et voilà on
souhaite à personne mais ça peut tomber
sur n'importe qui d'entre nous n'importe
quel moment de notre vie et aller au
généton c'est se rendre compte généton
Bioprod aussi enfin savoir que la FM
fait ses propres médicaments maintenant
alors qu'il y a quelques années on se
disait ces maladies orpheline jamais on
trouvera le moyen de le leur leur
trouver des traitements enfin voilà tout
ça ça fait que l'espoir est tellement
énorme qu'il faut surtout pas lâcher
maintenant c'est voilà c'est maintenant
qu'il faut y aller donc on y va et le
Téléton c'est aussi important donc pour
rencontrer les malade mais aussi pour
que les familles se rencontrent entre
elles vous rencontrez d'autres familles
aussi sur manie oui on a rencontré une
ou de de fois une famille mais bon on on
en voit pas tellement non plus il y a
des échanges qui se font tout de même au
niveau de la PF plutôt on voit des
parents au niveau de la PF au niveau de
la commune pas tellement mais au niveau
de la PF on voit quand même souvent des
parents qui ont d'autres problèmes hein
parce qu'il n'a pas que des stérose en
plaque mais il y a d'autres parents et
puis qui ont des problèmes plus
importants que les nôtres et vous serez
à manilamo mobilisé comme à chaque fois
pour ce Téléton vous serez où
précisément les gens qui veent venir
vous voation au sandwich voà au sandwich
am Man est à mot vous irez voir au deal
merci d'être venu sur ce pl
26h 26h 26h pas une de plus peut-être un
petit peu
plus plus toujours du mal à se dire au
revoir vers 22h le samedi c'est clair
sur RVVS 962 à partir de vendredi 19h
merci Richard je vous redonne aussi le
numéro de téléphone 3637 que vous
connaissez pour faire vos dons dès le
vendredi dès demain matin à 8h et
jusqu'à dimanche minuit ensuite ce sera
du lundi au vendredi et de 9h à 18h la
neige devrait faire son apparition dès
7ette nuit une alerte orange a
d'ailleurs été lancé dans 33
départements dont celui des Yvelines les
communes se préparent par exemple à
Montini le Bretonneux les saleuses vont
circuler dès 21h30 ce soir dès demain
matin à 6h également le département est
lui aussi mobilisé le plan neige a été
activé un plan lancé au lendemain de la
grande pagaille de décembre
2010 chacun se souvient des épisodes
neig jeux de l'hiver 2010 et des
automobilistes bloqués en fin
d'après-midi la leçon a été retenue et
depuis 2 ans les services plus que
mobilisés pendant ces mois d'hivers un
plan ilance a été mise en place dans le
département depuis quelques jours les
équipes de techniciens et cadres sont
mobilisé en astreinte 7 jours sur 7 et
24h sur 24 cette année comme l'an passé
les équipes du département vont
s'appuyer sur la participation de 15
agriculteurs afin d'être le plus réactif
possible en zone rurale comme urbaine
pendant l'hiver dernier le département a
connu de forts épisodes neigeux les
équipes de la Direction des routes et
des transports sont intervenu 104 fois
et 1900 tonnes de sel ont été utilisé
dès les premiers flocons de neige les
usagers pourront consulter les dernières
alertes de circulation ou de déneigement
sur le site internet du conseil général
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner avec
votre smartphone voilà en espérant qu'il
nige pas quand même à ce point-là durant
cette nuit la suite du 78 ce sera avec
la chronique écho d'Alice Gastine dans
un instant et puis aussi le lancement
sur Internet d'une radio dédiée au
reptiles oui vous avez bien entendu une
web radio dédié au reptiles nous
revenons déjà sur la nomination
infopolitique d'un nouveau délégué
général au Parti chrétien démocrate de
Christine Boutin à la conseillère
générale des Yvelines le conseiller
municipal de Montini le Bretonneux vient
d'hériter de ce poste lors de la
convention nationale du parti qui s'est
d'ailleurs déroulé à Versailles le
weekend dernier voici sa réaction ça
consiste d'une part en l'animation
interne du parti donc nos 75 délégations
10000 adhérents 250 élus locaux donc de
fédérer de coordonner l'animation et
d'autre part un rôle d'ambassadeur du
parti auprès des partenaires notamment
de l'UMP le parti se porte bien nous
avons eu plus de 110 dit candidat au
législativ nous avons fait un score
supérieur au modem par exemple et en
terme d'adhérent de sympathisant nous
nous nous nous avons à peu près les
mêmes chiffres que des partis comme les
Verts donc voilà donc le parti se porte
bien et se développe le Parti Chrétien
Démocrate est une valeur refuge à droite
un peu comme l'or les au sein de
l'économie on la voit passer au
quotidien mais on y pense peu et puis en
période de crise et ben on se souvient
que l'or est une valeur refuge c'est un
peu pareil pour nous vous pensez déjà
2014 moi je suis conseiller municipal à
Montini avec Michel logier voilà vous
resterez des discussions sont en cours
je suis conseiller municipal avec Michel
l
aujourd'hui